good morning I really appreciate that
sir to be here thank you and so you may
think I'd be talking about single-cell
genomic analysis but i'll actually be
talking about signaling analysis and i
think it's an important dimension that
the genomic immunity would benefit from
because i really think we need to start
integrating genomic thinking with
proteomic thinking and signaling so okay
in terms of an outline I will just
briefly describe single cells signaling
data and I'm you know many of you maybe
already familiar with it but because the
title was genomic analysis cancer i
thought i would give a few slides in
this and based on this signaling
heterogeneity talk about ways that we
identify intramural heterogeneity and
then use at inter tumor heterogeneity to
optimize potentially drug combination
strategies and so the last part would be
to look at signaling perturbations on a
single cell level in a single tumor to
think about how to put different
combinations of drugs together so this
is very much a work in progress you know
it is as I'll present it more of a
computational problem as opposed maybe
to a practical way of doing it but I do
think that there is something underlying
this data that you know will percolate
up and and help make decisions about
combination therapy in the future so
okay so many of you probably familiar
with facts analysis facs analysis
basically is you know a technology where
we look at you know we dissociate let's
say a tumor into single cell suspension
and we measure a number of markers
purcell a newer technology that is
becoming very popular now is called site
off which it basically it's the same
idea as facts in the sense that we
dissociate a sample into single cells
and we take measurements of on the
single cell level
and but the exciting ability of side
tough as unlike faxes that site off
enables us to measure 40 markers Purcell
as opposed to site up facts which was
more limited to more typically four to
eight maybe 12 markers Purcell so now we
have this technology we're in a single
sample across hundreds of thousands of
cells we have about 40 measurements and
we can we have some flexibility as to
picking which 40 things we want to
measure in that cell so we can measure
surface markers to maybe identify some
of the different cell states and then we
can have some of our panel measure
intracellular markers so that when when
we perturb those cells we can see
changes in those intracellular markers
now side top is a destructive technology
in the sense that you really do kind of
vaporize your cell and so if you want to
do a drug analysis on a population you
look at a sample before and then you
look at a sample after but you can't
look at the same cell before and after
so so this real-time is not going to be
captured here so then the issue becomes
if you want to look at differences in a
population you have to look at you have
to sort of think about subpopulations
and matching subpopulations and looking
at differences within those
subpopulations think about drug response
ok so when side top was first being
introduced know you know the tools that
were available and primarily used with
facts analysis in the lab or just
looking at biaxial plots and identifying
populations through sequences of biaxial
plots and in one of the datasets i'll
show you one of the first data sets that
we generated with this new technology
working in collaboration gary nolan who
introduced this technology to stanford
we measured
30 markers Purcell in normal bone marrow
and essentially that generated over
almost 500 biaxial plots so at the time
Gary's lab was generating this data the
issue was how to analyze it to get
information out of it so in my lab we
took this data and we started thinking
well what we know in normal bone marrow
is that as the cells that make up normal
Bell Mara are part of a differentiation
lineage starting with a poetic stem cell
and that lineage has surface markers
that recapitulated to through a myeloid
developmental process and a lymph node
developmental process and if you look at
these surface markers of cells in
different parts of this developmental
process whether or not it's like b-cell
development or neutrophil development or
you're through sites what you see in
traditional facs analysis is that these
surface markers that define these
certain cell types change gradually as
the cells differentiate so we decided to
use that property that you know that
there's a gradual change in the surface
markers to try to order the cells that
we got from the site off analysis in
some kind of branching structure in
order to make to give us a tool to to
try to make some inferences and so we
developed this tool called spade that
was published now several years ago
which is just graphically in a very
simple cartoon way illustrated here so
that and I walk through the different
steps of it the idea is that we take the
initial data and at the end whether or
not you know as here it's just two
dimensional data it's just two markers
Purcell or 40 markers Purcell we end up
with a tree as a minimum spanning tree
and and basically what we're doing is
ordering all the different cell
populations in in this tree so they have
different positions on the tree so to
get there we start with this in here
shown as two dimensional data and we see
this heat map that there's certain
regions that are very highly populated
regions that are more scarcely populated
and this problem most most people would
they would do is sort of randomly sample
but what would happen then is that you
would lose some of the scarcely
populated regions of this area so we
recommended a density dependent down
sampling approach so that essentially we
are representing all parts of this space
that's covered by these two markers
independent of the density of samples in
it and then we apply a hierarchical
clustering algorithm more sort of any
type of clustering algorithm really and
we kind of over cluster the data our
goal here is to just D dimensionalize
the data a bit so that we have maybe
hundreds instead of thousands of
independent components to event connect
through the minimum spanning tree and so
then after we create this minimum
spanning tree based on these meta
clusters we then up sample all those
cells that were part of the meta
clusters and now have a representation
of all the data and we we represented
often in terms of these bubbles along
the tree where the bigger bubbles are
more cells in potentially a meta cluster
as a bigger size bubble on this tree and
then we color code the tree depending on
whatever marker you're interested in
looking at ok so so when we applied this
algorithm to normal bone marrow data
this would be this is a result of the
tree and it was really comforting to see
that if you were to anchor the tree at
what was manually curated as
haemopoietic stem cell you would then
see that there was a branching that
depicted the myeloid lineage and a
branching that depicted the lymph node
lineage and as you move down the lineage
the cells of B cell differentiation T
cell differentiation and more than
myeloid differentiation were actually
ordered the way you would expect so and
and we realized that a lot of this
weaves because the surface markers that
were used to that were measured in the
analysis were already known to
characterize these different states but
the fact that it was able to put them in
an order that was what was known from
decades of researchers to normal
development in the him up wedeck process
was very reassuring so we wanted to
pursue inferences made with this
algorithm further okay so now here's the
type of inferences that one could make
and and I'm going to just briefly
describe them to move on to the purpose
you know the theme of my talk much more
of combination therapy so this is that
tree I showed you earlier and this is
now color coded by a surface marker cd10
which is known to be more highly
expressed in these pre b cells but if
you now move to a cancer sample and this
is a single sample from a pediatric
patient with a pre ba ll and you were
run that panel that was run on the
normal bone marrow and then run the
spade analysis this would be the result
and this population here cd10 cells
which was very small in the normal
samples now dominant in this leukemic
sample and it's placed on the tree right
next to this b cell so you're through
you know the beauty of these sort of
kind of similarity based distance
algorithms is that you can start making
inferences had you not known that this
was a linear that this cell was derived
from a normal b-cell you can start
making inferences about the potential
cell of origin
and so this is one area that one
direction that my lab has taken that
would be another talk so we have been
using this technology to think about
cell of origin for cancer and thinking
about cancer as differentiating itself
and then maybe having a differentiation
block okay there have been a number of
other algorithms have been developed to
analyze this type of data and don't
appear who many of you may know at
Columbia has developed this algorithm
called vizzini which is very commonly
used as well with site off type of data
analysis and the basic idea is that it
uses this Disney layout to look at this
data and then similarly assets which is
another tool very similar to visit II
basically uses at is needy composition
to to look into this high dimensional
data and identifies clusters at the same
time so we were asked by nature
protocols to actually write a review of
these different algorithms and and it's
impressed and how they compare to each
other so the details are actually in
there if you're interested one thing
that we were we brought we talked about
in this review is that Spade as a
minimum spanning tree will connect
everything in the all the cells together
and so and and the beauty of more tizzy
based approach is that you could see
maybe distinct clusters so in the nature
protocols paper we talked about how you
could potentially take the meta clusters
that were derived from Spade put it into
at is new framework and then within
those clusters run kind of a minimum
spanning tree and we introduced this
concept of a spade forest as opposed to
these trees okay but that's an event of
a side so that's to just introduce to
you
some of this type of data and single
cell analysis now the beauty of working
with this data is or this technology is
that you can now take these samples and
we just really talked about analyzing
all these individual cells based on
their surface markers but you can
perturb those samples and then see how
intracellular markers change very
shortly after they per their perturb and
so this is a graphic here saying we have
a number of healthy bone marrow samples
and maybe some cancer samples a lot of
the analysis we've done has been on
leukemic samples because it's already
really it's an on solid tumor so that
issued associating it is not impacted
our analysis and maybe relapse samples
from patients and and then you could
sort of perturb it with different types
of stimulations interleukins for example
and you then can measure changes really
in intracellular marker signaling
markers death markers and the assumption
is that these perturbations at least
shortly within maybe just within 30
minutes or maybe a few hours after their
perturbed the surface markers don't
change so you have this surface markers
that don't change with the perturbations
and they have these inter selling
workers that do change with the
perturbations okay so how do you now
think about using this type of data so
in the original paper where we had you
know introduced Spade for analyzing it
we had shown that with the Spade tree
you can look at where some of these per
debate where the perturbations make the
biggest impact by taking differences
between these trees so for example this
is an aisle seven perturbation looking
at stat5 signaling and if you look at
the tree before and after the
perturbation and sort of take a
difference then you'll see that that
effect was only limited to the T cell
population
so it was a very fast way of looking
into this very complicated data to see
where this perturbation was making a
difference and then and then now these
these two panels here are really setting
the stage for the next part of my talk
now these are looking at the
perturbations in the absence and
presence of death it nip which is a drug
that's a small molecule inhibitor and
now and this is just a normal bone
marrow and and the take-home message of
all of this is that we see that
dissented in this normal bone marrow
shows changes in the T cell or B cell
lineage under specific stimulation so
the concept here is that if there's
certain microenvironments in the tumor
the tumor is likely to respond
differently and so it's so this is sort
of sort of really sort of this is an
illustration of that and the concept of
microbio is really extrapolating from
this concept here but this is how we
take it so now here is this all the
cells in this tree and we're looking at
Earth's signaling and as a control we're
showing that and the presence or absence
of this drug there's no changes with
this particular stimulant ionno myosin
but then if you now look at a simulation
of the b-cell receptor in the presence
or absence of deaths in tipp you see a
big change in erk signaling depending on
the presence or absence of the end of
again this drug so you see a big change
only in this b cell lineage similarly
here you see a change in the t cell
lineage measured through step 5
signaling with provided at prevent
innate as a stimulant in the presence
and absence of the dasatinib here using
il-7 as a control okay so again this was
published and and all these results were
actually in a very long almost 200 page
supplement in the science paper so there
was a lot of data there the questions
now how do you put all of that response
data together and so that is really
where I'm what I'm proposing next but
order to do that what the basic idea is
that I will talk about later is you need
to look at the changes in signaling
within subpopulations and here the
subpopulations are identified for us
manually because we know the different
parts of teeth the different parts of
hemopoietic lineage and we know the t
cells and the b cells and the different
cells and the myeloid lineage but we
want in cancer we don't know the
difference of populations so we need a
way to use the surface markers to number
one identify the different populations
and then within the different
populations look at the difference in
the intracellular signaling okay so so
identify so that's so that's the next
part of my outline and I'll briefly talk
about an algorithm that we published to
identify in these complex data sets
subpopulations based on their surface
markers so so because the data sets are
really large we proposed an algorithm
that was published recently in plos
computational biology called cast that
basically creates a decision tree using
nonparametric statistics and so
essentially what we tried to do in
developing this tree was determine the
minimum number of surface markers that
would be used and the minimum number of
cuts that would be placed in the data in
order to identify the different
subpopulations within the sample and so
what we found in analyzing actual data
and we show here just graphically is
that what the alga kind in the data is
that some markers the cells with some
surface markers actually it's not a
continuous representation but it is
they have certain states at these
markers and ourselves some cells in
between those states and so some markers
have multiple Cup points and so we found
that there's a few markers that really
identify the difference of the
heterogeneity within the sample and and
it's really kind of a sort of a novel
idea because most people who sort on
these type of samples use different
markers anyway and when we use our
algorithm for example on a subpopulation
the normal bone marrow which is the
b-cells what had happened was that the
way the data was represented in our
original publication the samples were
manually gated and and when we looked at
intracellular signaling with these
different stimulation so each block here
is one stimulant under this five
manually gated populations and then we
have about seven different simulations
this was the changes in some of the
intracellular stata measurements of
these different 5 b cells under these
different simulations but when we ran
our algorithm on it we also found five
cell states but they were different and
we found that the cell states were much
more homogeneous of course based on the
surface markers because it was optimized
for that but then we found that the
intracellular signaling was actually
more robust so it was clear to us that
with the manual gating there was gating
of heterogeneous populations that made
the intracellular changes less you could
because you basically lost the signal
and the intracellular changes because of
the heterogeneity of the manual gating
okay so so that really are those are
really the main tools that will feed
into the next part of my talk which is
trying to use these concepts to now
identify optimal drug combinations based
on this perturbation analysis okay
so I have a postdoc in my lab Benedict
an chung who really developed this
algorithm and and i'll be describing it
very brief it but the idea is that if
you have a sample that's exposed to
let's say a single drug and you then
expose it to n different drugs and you
measure em targets some surface markers
from intracellular markers we'd like to
identify an optimal combination as the
minimum number of drugs that maximizes
the number of desired effects so if
you're measuring intracellular changes
signaling changes that you want survival
markers intracellular serveriron markers
that you want to see decreased that
would be a desired effect or if you want
to see a peptic markers you want to see
increase that would be in a desired
effect so and and we we measure these
desired effects by accounting for inter
tumor heterogeneity based on this cast
album that described before so we look
at every sub population within the tumor
and and then look at these effects
within those subpopulations so how does
this look at it it's sort of another
cartoon to just explain it so we have a
sample we treat it and then what we see
is that there's for example three
subpopulations based on surface markers
color coded here in red green and blue
and then we have these subpopulations
under drug s1 how they change on a drug
s2 and how they change on the drug
history so here are the the pot of the
three subpopulations and then we measure
you know here just three intracellular
signaling markers so these
subpopulations work differently under
have changed different changes in
intracellular markers under the
different drugs and so we summarize this
data as effects of probably of an effect
the probability that certain markers are
affected here we're just measuring three
markers in a subpopulation
in each of these three drugs and so we
have a Bayesian analysis to quantify the
probability in effect and we can do that
because there's quite a bit of data here
because each subpopulation has thousands
of sense of thousands of cells often in
it and then we take the effects and we
arrange we put them into a graphical
model and we create a nested graphical
model where we the graphical model is a
graphic model of the drugs and so the
idea is that some of the drugs that have
unique effects are higher up in this in
this graph or network and the drugs that
have shared effects are lower down so
for example drug s one has unique
effects in three populations II one in
the green population he wanted the Blue
population II two in the red population
and those effects are also shared by
drug s 2 and then drug s 3 has these two
unique effects and those are also shared
by drug s 2 so we say that drug s 2 is
nested in its effects within drug s 1
and drug s 3 so we create this nested
effects model that actually had been
previously introduced for a knockout
data on cell lines okay and then we
score and so we look at the minimum
number of drugs that maximize the number
of effects and based on knowing how they
how they're positioned within this
graphical model okay so I'm just going
to show a couple of examples actually
just one example where we have this cell
line a HeLa cell line ovarian cancer
cell line and we looked at three we
analyzed it under four conditions one
with trail which is known to induce
apoptosis but its associated quite a bit
of resistance and
then three small molecule inhibitors and
for simplicity once a mek inhibitor at
GDC of the other ones a p38 map kinase
inhibitor at GSK and other ones a pi3
kinase inhibitor SD and so then for each
of these conditions these markers are
measured these are survival related
markers and these are death related
markers okay and so the first thing we
do with this data is we get out cells
that have already committed to dying
because they are definitely in a
different cell state and then with those
remaining live cells we show them here
in terms of the death markers and we ran
those cells in our cks algorithm and NC
Cass identified three cell states that
were shared between the basal the
non-treated group and all the treated
groups and so we identified them here as
a pop one pop two and pop three blue red
and green and and show them here in
terms of interestingly very high RB
signaling with midranges of C parp this
is this population two in here and then
there's this cloud which is population I
mean population wine is this in here
with high high are being a relatively
high C part and then population two is
scattered around it and then a very
surviving population down here and so so
this is just to show that all of these
three conditions actually have cells
within all these three different
populations so now within these three
populations we create our effects matrix
which is a probability that each of
these different stimulate or drug
interventions had an effect on specific
markers and we do that separately for
each of the three populations and now if
you were to create that graphical model
of the drugs on each of the population
to see that the graphical model is
really different for each of the
populations which is no surprise because
this is explaining the inter tumor
heterogeneity but if
course we're not treating one population
at a time when we expose it to a drug we
treat all the populations at a time so
we take these effects and we put it into
one effects matrix and we create a
nested effects model based on that one
effects matrix and then we start scoring
that model for the optimal combinations
this here is another graphical model if
we had never taken to account the three
different subpopulations if we instead
look at the effects without which is
pulling all the single cell data
together and we see that that's a very
different graphical model and basically
this graphical model tells us there's an
equivalency between trill which was
really the drug of interest in this
particular study and all the other small
molecule inhibitors and we know for a
fact that's not true but this model
tells us that actually that this drug
jsk and trail that Jason jsk has
independent effects from trail or unique
effects that trail doesn't have and so
that if you were to pick two drugs for
example that the best to drugs would
presumably be trail in GSK so we undergo
our scoring function and and we rank the
becks combination of two drugs and and
three drugs and then in terms of
validation analysis all the combination
of the drugs were tested and the in
terms of and then measured in terms of
how many cells were surviving and and
it's it validated in terms of the
ordering we that we proposed for the
best two and three drug combinations
okay so that's that's that's it so in
summary I started this work and it with
with Gary Nolan and looking at how to
probe this high dimensional data by
hierarchy ordering these single cells
with the Spade analysis and and I found
it a very interesting direction of
research because it has an interesting
way of looking into inter tumor
heterogeneity and
and then thinking about potentially
combination drug strategies based on
perturbation analysis and so I think
that this is something that's worthy now
to couple with more genomic approaches
to capture that inter tumor a journey so
with that I just want to give a couple
of acknowledges i mentioned Benedict who
developed this nessa defects drug model
pong who developed a spade model and
very grateful to Gary he's been a
fantastic collaborator and these three
people are in his lab who have generated
a lot of the data we've been working
with and Rob subterranea statistician at
Stanford who's been helping us with the
statistics of some of these models and
two and this work was funded
specifically under one program through
the NCI the integrated cancer baljit
program so thank you for your attention
your model seems to it assume that you
give a cocktail of drugs the effect is
the union of the individual drugs
without other unfavorable interactions
how well does that actually work out in
practice yeah so we're in the process of
testing that there's no doubt there's a
synergy between these drugs and so we
are basically as you said looking at
them somewhat independently we by
nesting the effects we do see some
overlap I mean because we see where
things are common in terms of what's
being commonly targeted but we can't see
off target effects or anything like that
in the first part where you have this
algorithm that uses spanning trees that
structure reflecting somehow that
develop and help your factories in the
cellar is it of themselves I mean is
that what well it's you know it's just a
minimum spanning tree and it captured
that because the idea of spanning trees
you're looking at gradual variation you
know you're through the shortest
linkages you know if you add up all the
linkages is this minimum distances and
so that force is this gradual variation
and it's interesting to think that maybe
biology is like that too it's just
something we found when we started
looking at the data that it was
capturing a normal bone marrow and and
when we've applied to other
developmental trajectories in ESC cells
stem cells we see that it's seeming to
recapitulate but it's all a function of
the surface markers that you choose in
the analysis it does that answer your
question sort of wondering why if it is
developmental trajectories you can see
all the intermediate states
because you have those what yeah yeah
they're there other tissues you know
that's an interesting yeah I think that
the the self renewing tissues have many
of the intermediate States and so just
like the blood does yeah so I've also a
question about this level emmons a
result and have the clarification self
when you show those clustering and based
on based on spending they are drugs are
not a certain dependent was constructed
with all the market and then you show it
then in each of the cases under just
overlay on sentry or that the trees just
constantly
yeah so that's a great question so the
tree at by design is intended to be
fixed and then we map on it so we look
at because we can't follow individual
cells so we try to create what we think
is a structure before and after and we
map on that structure look at the
changes but as possible that if you do a
dynamically it's very hard to compare
before and after at that point yeah yeah
you could do that so we do pull the data
and what we you could see that different
like later time points populate
different parts of the tree as opposed
to earlier time points if you take
Samuel spanning-tree approach and maybe
if you're running on dark skin gene
expression data and so it can you see
the same structure that yes and in fact
the precursor algorithm to this was run
on like TCGA data in fact and we have
this paper sample progression discovery
which basically uses consensus minimum
spanning trees because now you have you
know tens of thousands well thousands of
genes and so that we're looking at high
variant and so I didn't talk about that
but it really was the initial idea came
from trying to order tumor samples and
to see if we can determine maybe a
differentiation hierarchy and tumor
samples and when we apply the algorithm
to hierarchies in normal developmental
biology it riccati captured those
hierarchies and so that was a launching
place actually for this work so that's a
paper and plows computational biology
sampled progression discovery
thank you very much